monter on a retrouvé le maître d'hôtel
il se cache dans les contreforts
s'éloigner proche du pic de gabelle
masters notre contact l'a convaincu de
vous rencontrer demain midi à
l'observatoire du sommet ne le dites à
personne
il vous expliquera tout votre train
partira dans quatre minutes trente
voilà goupillé troisième classe il était
complet mais le conducteur a été
sommelier au vieux versailles
il a fait jouer ses relations vous en
aurez besoin vrai qu'on reste en une
dernière chose il n'avait que le petit
flacon
vrai le remercier par un geste
symbolique combien l'argent tu veux
qu'ils rentrent de québec et trois
timbres posément 25
béni soit tu
je tends pouvait